nous recevons en invité du samedi 20h ce
soir Laurent Fignon mail à Monsieur
nous étions jeunes et insouciants chez
grâce est toujours en compagnie de
Christine Kelly
une Pierre Moscovici
alors Laurent Fignon Bonsoir vous
resterez dans l'histoire du cyclisme
français comme un des rares à avoir
gagné deux fois le Tour de France en 83
et 84
à l'époque il reçoit ici le maillot de
leader le dernier maillot serais
intéressé de Laurent Fabius Premier
ministre est Jacques Chirac maire de pas
voilà mais vous restera encore plus
comme celui qu'il l'a perdu de 8
secondes à la dernière étape en 89 voilà
vous n'êtes pas égaler le palmarès de de
Louison Bobet vous raconter tout ça dans
un livre qui paraît cette semaine et
vous annoncer parallèlement votre
concernant
pour faire le buzz vous êtes champion
pas fait exprès c'est un concours de
circonstances livre est terminé et j'ai
appris que j'avais malheureusement cette
maladie.
le cycliste
[Musique]
Laurent Fignon re bonsoir c'est grâce et
nous étions jeunes et insouciants où
vous racontez votre carrière dans le
cyclisme amateur et professionnelle
pendant les années 80-90 il commençait
d'autres bouquins par ce fameux tour 89
vous avez perdu à cause de 8 secondes et
c'est très poignant quand vous raconter
ça vous vous dites c'est des
Champs-Elysées avenue du martyr quoi
c'est vraiment
ce truc-là quoi c'est dur c'est très dur
à encaisser aujourd'hui on a même que ça
continue de me poursuivre ainsi pas
complètement à chaque fois qu'on en
parle on en parle tout le temps
je vous reconnais vous êtes celui qui a
perdu le tour de
celui qui a gagné deux en même temps
ça presse autour de 89 les gens sur la
route vous disais quand tu voyais passer
vas-y vite encore
en plus c'était pas toujours le cas la
grande révélation du bouquin c'est que
vous vous êtes dopés Laurent
aujourd'hui
parce que c'est trop dur
c'est de la triche
et
donc c'était pas pour les courses
aujourd'hui
on a le droit de prendre la cortisone
concert de sortie du marc je peux pas
dire même pas un soda qui est
énergisante je prends rien
dans le cyclisme pour moi qui ai fait un
livre sur un footballeur je me suis
beaucoup intéressé au football et je
trouve scandaleux qu'on ne parle pas du
dopage dans le foot alors insu ou pas
ils sont dopés après mon enquête
une vraie journaliste
William Gallas
parler avec lui mais du coup j'en ai
parlé avec beaucoup de personnes du
milieu et qui m'ont dit surtout ne
l'écris vais pas mais voilà et je peux
vous dire attelle match ceci et voilà
donc c'est scandaleux de faire autant
sur le dopage dans le cyclisme mais que
fait-on du foot pourquoi parce qu'il y a
trop d'argent je pourquoi tu es aussi la
cocaïne
c'est l'école des narcotrafiquants
c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce qui est bizarre c'est finalement avec
toute cette drogue dans le cycle 1 et je
ne sont pas spécialement attiré par sa
[Applaudissements]
le Tour de France pour France 2 comment
vous pouvez continuer à ces gens-là
alors que vous savez qu'en fait ils sont
un peu aider moi quand je comment je
suis plutôt du côté
technicien explique ce que je vous
voyais à l'antenne j'essaie de vous dire
pourquoi ça roule vite pourquoi ça roule
pas vite quelle tactique il peut y avoir
après effectivement de temps en temps il
y a des choses qui me semble un peu
bizarre mais je peux pas non plus
prendre position des filles je ne sais
pas vraiment
du tour autour duquel il y a pas eu des
rumeurs des ou des condamnations
une étape contre-la-montre du Tour
centre Fribourg et Mulhouse et j'étais
derrière l'allemand
il a foncé pendant 66 mètres 6 ans sans
respirer
j'arrive
on a l'impression que c'est toujours le
même
non mais quand je vois je vois le Tour
de France personnellement là je pars là
je suis très surprise par les marques
qui appartient
et juste pour savoir
voilà donc vous appréciez à sortir ce
livre qui je le dis vraiment passionnant
et là vous avez appris le 20 mars que
vous aviez le cancer quoi c'est un
cancer des voies digestives tout ce que
l'on sait donc pourrais semblablement
plutôt estomac pancréas ça change pas
grand-chose finalement
est-ce que vous
avez pris à l'époque ou non
musique je vais faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour pas y passer c'est bien mais j'ai
déjà commencé mais j'ai changé mon
alimentation bien sûr que j'ai pas peur
de mourir j'ai une belle vie quand même
ça va aujourd'hui c'est vrai quand on
m'a annoncé ça forcément c'est la
première chose à laquelle on pense que
c'est une maladie mortelle et puis je me
suis dit mais moi ça me fait pas peur
est-ce que c'est parce que justement
j'ai une belle vie c'est vrai que le
livre parle de tout ça avant
peut-être que c'est ça je sais pas mais
j'ai pas envie par contre j'ai vraiment
pas envie
[Musique]
comment dans le tour sur France
Télévision voilà il y a beaucoup de gens
courage courage à toute la France est
avec vous il y a vraiment tout le monde
vous tout le monde vous soutiens de
support message de sympathie ça m'a fait
je peux pas répondre à tout le monde
mais je remercie tout le monde
mais pour être sûr de ne rien rater
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu